les indicateurs du coc vie 19 continue
de virer au rouge sur le territoire
français olivier vers on doit tenir
aujourd'hui à 18 heures son point
hebdomadaire sur l'épidémie avec à la
clé peut-être d'autres décisions
destinées à lutter contre la propagation
du virus
face à l'accélération des contaminations
le gouvernement a déjà imposé depuis
lundi dans onze villes dont paris et
lyon la fermeture des salles de sport et
des barres à 22h des mesures prévues
jusqu'ici pour 15 jours à aix marseille
en guadeloupe les bars et restaurants
ont fermé totalement l'annnonce de
nouvelles restrictions serait
catastrophique pour les syndicats du
secteur contre la force de l'état c'est
très difficile parce que nous ne sommes
que des petits cafetiers les petits
restaurateurs mais je pense qu'on sera
entendu pour l'ensemble de la population
parce que les gens ne peuvent pas se
résigner à être revus depuis tchèque à
haut-mauco aucun endroit pour les
accueillir pour se nourrir pour boire un
coup pour vivre les secteurs économiques
touchés sont en alerte et certains élus
locaux se dresse frontalement contre ces
décisions
malgré cette fronde re emmanuel macron
en déplacement à riga n'a fermé aucune
porte
le ministre de la santé les membres du
gouvernement compétent auront à
s'exprimer et annoncer les décisions
prises et les ajustements
le gouvernement doit pouvoir prendre des
mesures additionnelles nécessaires en
fonction de l'évolution de l'épidémie et
chaque mesure prise à un temps de vie de
15 jours parce que c'est le temps qui
permet de voir son efficacité
auditionné la semaine dernière par la
commission d' enquête du sénat olivier
vers en avait appelé les parlementaires
au courage et à la responsabilité
l'assemblée nationale doit en effet se
prononcer aujourd'hui sur les outils aux
mains du gouvernement pour les prochains
mois des pouvoirs allant de la fermeture
de restaurants à la restriction des
déplacements
le texte de deux articles objet d'une
centaine d'amendements devrait être
adopté en fin de journée avant que le
sénat l'examinera pidement un nouveau
projet de loi sur le sujet de
lui arriver d'ici à janvier 2021 le
gouvernement travaillerait un dispositif
pérenne de gestion de l'urgence
sanitaire en lieu et place de ces
rendez-vous intermédiaire de prorogation
des mesures transitoires devant le
parlement